teum en conséquence indirecte de ce coup
de froid une intoxication à l'oxydé de
carbone s'est produite dans un squat à
paris les locateurs de fortune privée
d'électricité
c'était chauffés au gaz 15 personnes
dont 12 enfants ont été évacués anne
font signer à l'insa ça saute aux yeux
l'immeuble est non conforme aux normes
des aides alors l'électricité a été
coupée dans ce bâtiment de ménilmontant
en mars dernier et depuis les familles
qui le squat c'est clair et se chauffent
au gaz butane
tant et si bien que le souci de sécurité
s'est retourné contre eux la nuit
dernière douze enfants et quatre adultes
ont été hospitalisé victime d'une
intoxication à l'oxydé de carbone et
d'un joueur on a peur parce qu'il ya une
famille ici tout le monde ces chercheurs
avec le gaz peut-être que demain ça sert
un nom peut-être la plaine et mal de
familles on a peur commence à ce qu'est
ce qu'ils ont les enfants c'est carlos
disant mal mal à la tête
mal au ventre et des vomissements aussi
en janvier 93 déjà l'immeuble avait été
évacué suite à l'explosion d'une
bonbonne de gaz
le lendemain les habitants avaient pu
revenir des familles que selon le comité
droit au logement on ne peut pas classer
comme cas sociaux cds famille
complètement organiser les enfants sont
scolarisés ya aucun problème de
relations avec les écoles il sait des
gens dignes les hommes travaillent
quelques femmes qui travaillent aussi
c'est pas le quart monde ça n'a rien à
voir avec le quart monde ils vivent dans
des conditions du quart monde
ces familles sont toutes en demande de
logements ce soir certains enfants sont
rentrés chez eux mais comme il fait
toujours aussi froid on continuera de se
chauffer au gaz